um for you on on this uh on this new
album how cool was it to uh give the
fans I mean I know we're going to we're
when when's the album drop April's I
think first week in April first week of
April but how cool is it going to be to
give the fans some new EPMD after all
these years yeah I mean it's so crazy
how how the label be like yo I like the
EPM D Record and I'm like are you saying
because of me you know what I'm saying
but I think that I just think that the
fans are going to be happy if I was on
there burping right because it's a it's
just a cuz it's a new EPMD song yeah or
new Cyprus Hills right you know so
people oh yeah the mob deep [__] is
crazy because because of
prodigyy so so but again when people
hear it they like oh okay and then
hopefully I did my job
for it to feel like it's supposed to
feel likez don't forget our
colleagues don't go because they either
scared or like you said the records
don't come out correctly right right
right right right you know so hopefully
I was able to correct it to too like
when I was when I was here with Dre as
you see on my on Instagram when I was me
and Dre was in studio everybody know it
went
viral me and Dre made five records you
know
and and he made three in one night crazy
you know off of my production though and
then I did we did another one with
Snoop that supposed to be on the new on
the new Snoop record and and I also did
one with him that me and him rhymed on
which was crazy wow you know um but
again Kevin it's just a blessing because
I don't want to I I never talk so I hate
to be big and biging up myself cuz I'm
not used to doing that I always been
introvert always been quiet but again at
the end of the day a lot of dope [__]
has happened in the last couple of years
for this to be what this is don't for
this is only volume one so is is it
going to be a Duos thing after of course
okay Dynamic du is my my brand I mean of
course so so so so now it's a brand that
me make it so I'm already in in like um
saying you know um you know with with
with um saying about the Larry and and
the source Walkers and all these people
that I'm looking at to do music with you
know the the the Cordes the Freddy Gibs
all these other you work with Freddy yet
I worked with Freddy back in 2014 okay
when he was on inter scope or no no 2014
no no no that was uh that was uh that
was around the time he put out uh
bandana or pinata yeah but I was I was
there before that I've been he's been
one of my best friends since about 2010
remember the DJ that was um what's the
DJ name the one that um that he was
signed to First in 2008 2009 the the ski
yeah I'm back there at he working with
ski yeah yeah yeah I'm that time so I
listen kev's one of the goats man no
rappers that rapped didn't come to me
that's fine none if you was rapping if
you was a rapping ass [__] you
know what I mean you had no no cuz only
a few of us did production right you
only going to go for to a few people
right that's crazy yeah